not a great day for everyone tough day
for Pete Budaj edge fans yeah yeah Pete
Budaj edge ended his historic campaign
as the first openly gay candidate and
then endorsed Joe Biden yeah yeah Pete
said the hardest thing I've ever had to
do is come out as a Biden supporter
that's the biggest shower telling
parents crazy we've you know we've had a
bunch of billionaires running and and
Tom Steyer just dropped out yeah people
were now starting to leave the race now
we have I think only eight hundred
Democratic candidates well here's what
it came out about Tom Steyer it's been
reported that for every vote he got
before we dropped out former
presidential candidate Tom Steyer spent
$3,300 per vote yeah yeah Bernie Sanders
said that's obscene Mike Bloomberg said
that's a pretty good deal reasonable by
the way Mike Bloomberg's longtime
girlfriend is campaigning for him by
herself without him just by herself yeah
Bloomberg's girlfriend said it's really
nice to finally wear heels sorry problem
for the father
you should trump on the news the other
he was giving us he's making fun of
Bloomberg at the day and he's he was
making fun of him and he was lowering
himself down out of the brain and I was
I started laughing I'm sorry I thought
you know that's classic leader of the
free world he's a mime who knew he's a
mime